my most recent paycheck on twitch was  8.6 k  but the issue with that is  because the brits took half of the irish  land  i get taxed 60 on everything ireland  doesn't have a treaty with america like  uk does so i'll pay twitches tax irish  tax and i'll pay la tax it  totals to 60 percent  so i do make good money but more than  half of it gets taken do you find that  demotivating though why am i doing all  this work when i get to keep 40  it is when the tax time comes around and  i see my friends paying way less but  it's also like i still have this insane  opportunity even with the amount of tax  i pay it's better than what i was doing  in ireland yeah but it's just a bit  annoying